MOUDI: I came here to the
United States a month ago,
after I escaped my country,
and I think it's time to expose
what's going on there.
[music playing]
The penalty in Saudi Arabia
for somebody like me,
who opposed the
government, is beheaded.
ARWA: There are so many things
that women can't do in Saudi,
because it's law.
They can't do anything without
a male guardian's consent.
MOUDI: When I was in
Saudi Arabia, if I wanted
to even go to the
supermarket, I have to inform
everyone in the house.
DANAH: I couldn't drive.
My father wasn't even thinking
about teaching me how to drive,
because it's against the law.
ARWA: The laws in Saudi are
doing that systematically
to discriminate against women.
Nobody talks about it.
MOUDI: Guardianship
system-- it's a slavery.
It's the worst human
rights violation.
DANAH: Sometimes, you feel
like your life is worthless.
ARWA: I felt like I was
nothing but a commodity.
What really scares me is that
I wouldn't get this asylum
and I would be returned,
and then I would die young,
and that I would lose
everything I tried to build--
that I would just fail.
[music playing]
MOUDI: I escaped in the night.
ARWA: My father was still
awake, and he was watching TV.
I was really scared
if he would notice
that I'm going out of my room.
MOUDI: I was prepared
that, in any second,
I'm going to be dead.
ARWA: I haven't heard my
parents' voice since I left
Saudi, and I wish I never do.
DANAH: Girls back home,
they're suffering.
And some of them,
they can't speak.
So since I'm here and I'm in
a free country, I can talk.
I can help them.
ARWA: I felt extremely
scared when I first got here,
and I still feel that same fear.
Will I be able to make it?
Or am I just going to fail?
[music playing]
All I really want is just to
live normally without fear
and not have to pretend
to be somebody else.
That's all I ever want.
-Do you have your
work authorization?
ARWA: Yes.
-OK, thank you.
[sniffling]
ARWA: I feel like this is
what I've always wanted,
ever since I've
decided that I don't
want to live in Saudi anymore.
But this is-- this is what
I've been working towards.
I want to go back to a
17-year-old me and tell her,
"You're going to do it."
I feel like I want to go and
just talk to other Saudi girls
that go through this,
leaving their homes
and being ostracized by their
families, having no one.
You know, you can do it too.
[music playing]